this video is sponsored by fabulous the
number one self-care app to help you
build better habits and achieve your
goals go to thefab.co real science to
get 25 off your fabulous subscription
[Music]
we homo sapiens have been eating meat
since the beginning of our very
existence
archaeologists have found marks on bones
from hacking tools that suggest we have
been carnivorous as far back as 3.4
million years ago when some of our
earliest hominid ancestors were
beginning to roam the earth
and all that protein and fat content of
meat was crucial to the development of
humans as we know them the theory
roughly goes that by moving to a meaty
diet we were freeing up energy used in
digesting plants and diverting it to
building bigger brains
however these evolutionary changes came
in an era of hunter-gathering where if
you wanted some meat you had to get your
spear out and go hunting
fast forward half a million years and we
can order a big mac delivery without
leaving the sofa globally we consume
over 365
million tons of it every year
the top meat-eating countries like the
us and australia annually eat around 120
kilograms per person and our meat
consumption is only set to continue as
developing countries grow richer more
people can afford more and more meat
and developed nations are also predicted
to keep increasing their meat
consumption
and this quick and easy access to meat
we have now is contributing to a climate
catastrophe
the meat industry is one of the biggest
contributors to greenhouse gas emissions
with one recent study finding food
production as a whole contributed a
third of all greenhouse gas emissions
across the globe
many think it's time to cut out meat
altogether from our diets for good
reason but unfortunately it's hard to
reverse these meat-eating trends
there's nearly nothing you can say to
convince people to give up something
that they've always had but what if
there was a way to have our beef and eat
it too
what if there was a way to keep eating
meat without slaughtering a single
animal while it seems far-fetched this
is the reality that many scientists are
working to achieve it's a technology
mired in controversy and a web of
complex economics but many are holding
on hope that it could be the way to save
our planet lab-grown meats could replace
the global need to raise and kill
animals and it's a reality that many
think is fast approaching
how can it be possible to grow meat in a
lab completely circumventing the
slaughterhouse
and will the process ever be
economically viable enough to match our
insatiable meat appetites
the idea of growing meat without killing
any animal has been around for a
surprisingly long time
in 1931 winston churchill even said we
shall escape the absurdity of growing a
whole chicken in order to eat the breast
or wing by growing these parts
separately under a suitable medium 82
years later his prediction would become
a reality the first lab-grown burger was
eaten in 2013 and since then it has been
a race to market for dozens of food tech
startups
lab-grown or cultured mates use
practices from regenerative science to
grow meat without needing to grow an
animal it all starts with stem cells
stem cells are a special type of cell
that have the potential to become almost
any type of cell found in the body
skin cell muscle cell liver cell etc to
harvest stem cells technicians have to
go to the primary source of the desired
meat directly to the cow here they take
a sample of tissue directly from the
animal without killing it or even
harming it
from this tissue they then isolate
multi-potent stem cells such as muscle
stem cells
these are put into a bioreactor with a
mixture of nutrients amino acids growth
hormones and a special serum called fbs
these ingredients promote the cells to
start replicating and keep the cells
alive and happy
then by adding different growth factors
technicians can prompt the cells to
differentiate or turn into the required
type of cell like muscle or fat
muscle cells will naturally move
together in the suspension to form
myotubes these tubes can then be
essentially mushed together to make beef
burgers if the origin is cow cells or
chicken nuggets if the origin is chicken
cells and so on
a single muscle stem cell could be grown
into one trillion muscle cell tubes
that's a lot of burgers and nuggets from
one tiny cell
but this is as far as innovators have
come creating essentially lab-grown
ground beef it's not possible yet to
simply grow a whole steak or a wing or a
filet or a chicken breast
but there's one glaring problem here
with creating this animal-free meat it's
not actually animal-free
that special fbs serum i just mentioned
that stands for fetal bovine serum which
is collected from the dying fetuses of
slaughtered cows it's pretty gruesome
and so far scientists have not found a
way to create lab-grown meat without it
why is it so important and is there any
way around it
fetal bovine serum is a serum made from
the blood of cow fetuses
if a cow is going for slaughter and
happens to be pregnant the fetus is
removed and its blood drained all while
it dies a slow death the fetus is kept
alive for as long as possible during
this process to ensure the quality of
the blood remains good
the blood is then refined resulting in
fetal bovine serum or fbs
and so far all lab-grown meat requires
this serum
when the stem cells are removed from the
animal as i mentioned they are placed in
a bioreactor tank to replicate and grow
and here the fbs is added
fbs prevents the replicating stem cells
from committing suicide normally cells
have a mechanism that tells them they're
growing in the wrong place and shuts it
down
this is normally a good thing and keeps
different parts of the body developing
properly
but when cells are growing in a metal
tank and not a body this warning system
needs to be turned off
and for whatever reason fbs works almost
completely universally when added to any
type of cell that cell will start to
replicate and grow whether it's chicken
beef fish or muscle skin or liver cells
other serums do exist but none are so
versatile
as of now fbs is the essential
ingredient to lab-grown meat an
ingredient that completely defeats the
purpose of artificial meat
in fact it's probably even worse than
the traditional slaughterhouse
to make a single lab-grown beef burger
an estimated 50 liters of bovine serum
is needed
and depending on age a single cow fetus
can yield between 150 and 550
milliliters of serum that means to
create a single burger you need the
blood of between 90 and
333 cow fetuses
until a synthetic or plant-based
alternative to fbs is found
slaughter-free widely available
lab-grown meat is completely unfeasible
and fbs isn't easy to replace it
contains approximately 1800 different
proteins and more than 4 000 metabolites
some scientists have succeeded in
creating synthetic serums but all of
them are hyperspecific to the type of
cell being cultured none are capable of
replacing fbs to culture all possible
cell types
however recently a glimmer of hope has
emerged in one company producing a
synthetic alternative something they
call fast grow they say its components
are not derived from human or animal and
it promises to be able to replace fbs
for a range of different cell cultures
but so far no independent studies seem
to have confirmed its effectiveness
across the wide range of uses that would
be needed for lab grown meat and in
general creating serum free media is
hugely expensive a recombinant protein
like transferrin can go for 260 dollars
a gram growth factors like tgf beta can
cost several million dollars a gram more
expensive by weight than diamonds
the price tag for fast grow as a whole
is around two thousand six hundred and
forty dollars per liter
there is reason for hope but also reason
for skepticism
scaling lab-grown meat up for mass
production is going to have quite the
price tag perhaps a prohibitive one and
it's not just the serum that gets costly
everything about the lab-grown meat
process from ingredients to facilities
is eye-wateringly expensive
the cost of lab-grown meat will be a
nearly impossible hurdle to overcome
a pound of lab-grown meat using current
technology and at current scale is
estimated to cost around ten thousand
dollars according to the good food
institute there are a few reasons why
lab-based meat is so expensive
first the regular animal-based fbs is
between 300 and 700 for a liter and to
scale up lab-grown meat companies need a
large volume
some estimate 50 liters are needed for a
single burger but even if this number
drops significantly the price tag will
still be in the hundreds if not
thousands
and if moving away from fbs is the goal
as we discussed synthetic versions are
likely to be even more expensive
scaling up production will also be
necessary to reduce costs but in a catch
22 scaling up will cost the business big
bucks
to create the kinds of volumes of meat
required for the carnivorous public
huge bioreactor vats will be needed to
grow the meat products to acquire one
kilogram of protein from cultured muscle
cells the meat company would need a
bioreactor with a volume of about 5 000
liters
that's like the biggest beer fermenter
that exists all for a single kilo of
meat to expand and differentiate the
cells have to be kept at a fairly low
density so these massive tanks are
needed until researchers learn how to
raise a higher density culture and there
are other problems too a vat of cultured
meat has no immune system if a virus
particle gets in that can infect the
cells it absolutely will
this would kill the cells and kill the
entire batch of product food grade
facilities wouldn't be good enough to
prevent such an infection they'd need to
be pharmaceutical grade to keep the meat
cells free from any contamination and
you can bet a pharmaceutical grade
facility will be way more expensive than
a food grade one
plus when you're building a burger from
scratch in the lab it's hard to get the
right components in the right quantities
and ratios to achieve that delicious
meaty flavor in 2020 singapore became
the first country to approve lab-grown
meat for commercial consumption
food journalists were on the fence about
the flavor and texture of u.s companies
eat just chicken nuggets it wasn't bad
but it wasn't quite like chicken either
scientists are still working on getting
that juicy bloody melt-in-the-mouth
element of meat into lab-grown versions
as real meat contains thousands of
flavor molecules from proteins fats
ketones alcohols and other compounds
despite these massive financial barriers
many are still holding out hope
the good food institute recently
published an optimistic analysis
they think that addressing certain
technical costs will lower the
production price from over ten thousand
dollars per pound today to about two
dollars and fifty cents per pound over
the next nine years they believe that
the costs of certain aspects of the
process like growth factor costs may
indeed go down as the industry matures
they predict that one day soon growth
factors can be produced through
recombinant expression where bacteria or
yeast are genetically modified to
produce certain desirable proteins
this is already done to produce enzymes
relatively cheaply for various products
today
to modify this technology to produce
growth factors on a large scale may not
be that far-fetched however the price of
all aspects of the lab-grown meat
process going down anytime soon sort of
is farfetched but there is still room
for optimism we often see with new
biotech innovations a version of moore's
law exponential progress
take genome sequencing the first genome
took about a billion dollars to sequence
now 20 years later it's around a
thousand dollars
judging by the 300 million euros of
investment in lab-grown meat companies
in 2020 alone
there is hope if not an expectation for
this kind of trajectory if food tech
companies can continue to innovate and
experiment
perhaps using ai robotics and genetic
engineering technologies we might not
have to settle for a totally meat-free
future just a new kind of burger
personally i struggle to cut out meat
from my diet when talking about the
world's meat appetite i'm aware that i'm
part of the problem and while i don't
agree entirely with putting the onus on
the consumer to make environmental
change i think there's simply a decent
moral argument to try to just eat less
meat
but sticking to habits is hard i have a
few good ones like i shower i run i
occasionally clean the inside of my
microwave but sometimes all the best
ambitious plans just fall to the wayside
because it's simply overwhelming because
of this i'm a huge fan of making lists
but lately even lists aren't enough to
keep me on track to actually build good
habits i needed something more fun more
engaging and more motivating so recently
i've started using fabulous
fabulous is an app that helps you build
routines over time by breaking habits
down into small attainable steps the app
directs you to different journeys which
are programs that help you reach a
specific objective such as feel
energized sleep better focus and
concentrate or eat healthier journeys
start by setting up a healthy morning
routine
with fabulous you can go at your own
pace i cannot stand when famous and
successful people tell you that in order
to achieve your dreams you have to wake
up at 5 30 am to exercise for an hour
before prepping your kale breakfast and
clearing your inbox all before 8am i
have never done this i will literally
never do this i would rather die than do
this but the pressure of having the
perfect morning routine makes me just
avoid any routine altogether
historically my morning routine is
snoozing my alarm for 45 minutes but now
with fabulous i set my morning routine
to begin at 8am and give myself an hour
to complete a handful of simple but
important tasks that i sometimes would
neglect to do otherwise this routine
that fabulous has helped me build makes
me start the day not feeling frazzled
and mildly depressed instead i feel
energized and grounded knowing that i've
taken steps to take care of myself
before taking on the day
i'm also now working to set goals to
reduce my meat consumption by planning a
few vegetable-based dinners per week
over time you're able to add more habits
to your journey also known as habit
stacking
this is a common technique used to
sustain long-term routines
the app allows you to customize your
routines and choose the habits you want
to stack
fabulous is a great app for anyone
looking to improve their daily life and
can especially help if you struggle with
chronic fatigue want to increase your
energy levels can't sleep at night can't
concentrate or have anxiety so if you
want to build healthy habits that stick
go to the fab dot co
real science the first 100 people who
click on the link in the description
will get 25 off their fabulous
subscription as always thanks for
watching and if you're looking for
something else to watch right now you
can watch my latest video about sea
turtle conservation or you can watch
real engineering's latest video about
the loudest plane ever made
[Music]